Here's how I ended up
simplifying things.
I'd love to see great testing ideas.
So, if you're particular
to what you've created,
post your solution to the the forums.
I'm starting off
re-factoring things a little bit.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to add a function
to get the location ContentValues.
This will be useful when we actually
try to use these tests
for some other things later on.
And there we are: a function
that'll return location ContentValues.
I'm also going to pull the city name out,
so we can use that
for some validation steps later on.
And there we are.
It's now inside of the function.
Then we're simply
going to call that function
to get our location ContentValues
and we can delete all those lines of code.
Now, all of these columns,
as I said before, are not very important,
so we can delete them.
We can also null out the value
in our query.
The next thing I want to do
is actually fix this validation step.
What we can do is
we can create a function
that relies on the fact
we can get the map and set
from our ContentValues,
then we can simply iterate
through those.
Then we can see if the values
that we used to create the record
actually passed the values
in the cursor that are returned.
Now, back to our test. So, there's a lot
of unnecessary code here now.
All we have to do is call validateCursor
with our values and our cursor.
All right. So now we've converted
the first test. We can do the same thing
with the second test as well.
First of all, let's do
the same abstraction we did before.
Now of course, one of these values
isn't going to be static,
so we have to add that in.
Now we can say,
ContentValues=getWeatherContentValues,
with our all important location RowID.
Remember, our tables are linked.
Then we can insert it into the database.
Query for it. If the query is successful,
we can just call validateCursor again
on our weatherValues
with our weatherCursor.
So much less code.
And that's it.
Our test is vastly simplified
and it will be useful to us later on.
So now we can try running
this test again to see if it still works
after the re-factoring.
And there we are, test passed.
Now, it'd probably be useful for us
to actually print out some more data
so we can see what was being tested.
But, this simplification to our test
is going to help us as we move forward.
We're not done with testing yet.